[music]
the train from you need to the third and
forum d'avignon is good in bonn
conference on business
law
school in germany
[music]
just picked up in koblenz both team from the
forum ruhr way to the conference to the
utah jazz ofterdinger das  kuvert
network of highly modified
business
areas
[music]
exactly applies here about conference area
workshop in the main port aua get
francisco london for several days most
of that and certain age one of those is
just add some good land but for
professional
[music]
location des  festivals lay vista like the
electric brush at st gallen gmbh
program
experience
at julia talk about the pages
professional communications lighting
technology are external problem solving
skills so typical fans of
the dark men's consultant toolkit from april
stevens will benefit companies especially
the business background wanna make their
way into professional services lead
consulting services as well as focus of the
day becomes so many great  discussions crash
in spa des patients for students
and
pleasure to be here now with vanessa
patrick henry canaria before
master student david page you here in
wallendorf you have here from all you what
it's like to study a chip private
business school
of business school in germany
and
let  me hear you what is starting pitcher
university
community
manager
fastest growing startup in germany we
believe unicorn just a couple of months
also of which awards saints story
in the like what you just at the moment
where we knew the answer from
joachim rippel moment moments of
experience
[music]
to the pictures i think that is force
one of the reasons why people like to go
to business guttenberg the cost of
the carmina whether it loves
thats it with david university agresso
how the patting what i like here a
walking skin are there  help you
to get into the track
[music]
an arab justin started to get the wall to
the vastness of the b company 2 with children
k  empters right with a
consultant of it all things were
online portal even the work and campus
and max payne the enabling factor
this rating this very unique
forged
harms
so yes then before the session for today and
back on the way to munich re would have
amazing part  of judaism on energy in
tutorials people understand the visions
of consumer best
solution
for you tube
subscribe to the change up to date or
the content of corrections ran me
comment below in the comments actions of
channel switches instagram links tik
tok and witsch my name is heinrich
allison jewelers every single the big
pictures of the
best
da
[music]